elle est ce qu'on est pas mal vous
emmène avec vos vacances à l'île maurice
on va parler de sécurité de mac on va
parler de sécurité non sécurisé votre
ordinateur dont il a eu sa part fait
compris mais regardez juste avant
regardez là là où je vous en êtes je
partis pendant quelques jours en
vacances en famille à l'île maurice par
de se ressourcer en attaque et une
rentrée et là je suis sur un spot vous
avez un ordinateur qu'un ordinateur vous
avez derrière un autel qui est
complètement en travaux qui est en train
d'être refait et là n'est pas trop mal
au niveau météo un peu de pluie de temps
en temps bon c'est les i dans cette
saison c'est tout c'est pas la meilleure
période mais on est quand même plutôt
pas mal
donc l'idée aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement de vous parler de sécurité
je vous parle d'un logiciel qui
s'appelle intego c'est une vidéo qui est
sponsorisée réalisé en partenariat avec
intego pour vous présenter leurs
solutions pour mac c'est une entreprise
qui est spécialisée dans la sécurité
pour les nac depuis très longtemps
depuis même avant l'an 2000 succède 1996
si je vous dis pas de bêtises
l'idée aujourd'hui c'est effectivement
je vous dis attention on croit souvent
que les mac sont des ordinateurs
sécurisaient la part de douane par fait
part d'un antivirus pas besoin de
sécuriser et croyez moi c'est une
grossière erreur
ce que je fais c'est ou non exactement
la solution ce que peut vous proposer
cette société qui édite ce logiciel est
à vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
en banque en terre et croyez moi si vous
avez un mac prenait très au sérieux la
question de la sécurité internet parce
que je vois ça pourrait vous jouer des
tours
[Musique]
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que de plus
en plus de menaces sur internet et le
mcs malgré le fait qu'on est bien
longtemps pensé qu' avec globalement
adverys sur mac eh bien il fait pas
exception il ya également des virus sur
mac est justement là il ya le chèque est
très intéressant c'est intego vous avez
la partie complète en tout cas la partie
la plus premium qui s'appelle le mcs
premium bundle x 9 quai en gros une
suite de logiciels qui complètement
optimisé pour venir sécuriser et
protéger votre mac vous avez la partie
contente barrière qui est un contrôle
parental qui est un contrôle parental
pour justement sécurisé là où vos
enfants si vous en avez vous allez voir
un petit peu là où ils vont aller sur
internet net barrière qui est à un
firewall pare-feu netupdate servir à
faire effectivement comme son nom
l'indiqué les mises à jour personal
backup pour sauvegarder votre ordinateur
gens parlant quelques instants virus
barrier à cattenom antivirus et washing
machine qui vous servira complètement
venir optimiser votre bécane alors on va
se concentrer tout de suite sur la
partie peut-on antivirus une partie très
général avec virusbarrier alors comme
vous le voyez là votre ordi et protégé
analyse en temps réel activé dès qu'il y
aura un virus là potentiellement venir
taper à la porte de votre ordi et bien
au parc il va venir le bloquer j'ai donc
mac et sécurisée avec la liste complète
mon disque dur qui autorise et l'analyse
en temps réel activer la navigation
sécurisée est également activée alors si
je peux venir planifié si je le souhaite
je n'ai pas fait mais je veux dire
planifié ici pour voir si j'ai des virus
une périodiquement par semaine par jour
comme vous voulez une navigation
sécurisée activé ce que mal de petites
possibilités bon là voyez j'ai pas fais
l'analyse complète mais dans l'absolu ça
fonctionne j'en ai pas mais définition
installés sont les plus récentes les
gens souhaitent une zone de quarantaine
j'ai ensuite déficit de confiance que je
ne souhaite pas analyser tout ça c'est
pour toute la partie antirusse et croyez
moi c'est hyper important parce que les
virus et les malwares
il y en a de plus en plus sur mac il ya
beaucoup de pirates qui développe sur
mac parce que justement il ya beaucoup
de personnes qui pensent qu'il n'y a
absolument aucun risque sur moi qui
croyais moi il ya des risques comme sur
pc c'est une idée préconçue il faut donc
protéger son mac comme sur un pc donc
c'est plutôt cool et en plus ya tout qui
est intéressant c'est que vous êtes
protégé contre les malwares qui sont
présents sur mac mais également sur pc
comme ça quand vous transférer des
fichiers à quelqu'un tout la carpe et
c'est bien vous ne risquez pas de le
contaminer donc ça c'est plutôt cool
c'est intéressant ça protège également
pour tous les appareils ios que vous
allez connecter à votre mac vous êtes
protégé de tous les côtés donc ça c'est
cool
vous avez ensuite net barrière nette
barrière qui est le pare feu qui est le
firewall comme on dit
qui vous protège contre les intrusions
contre les intrusions pardon dans votre
ordinateur en gros l'idée c'est ça c'est
que tout ce qui est d'internet passe par
un pare-feu maintenir être contrôlés et
on va contrôler effectivement pour vous
n'ayez pas de problème vous réglez ça
comme vous voulez c'est très pratique
c'est sécurisé et vous êtes surtout
trois points d'accès alors regardez vous
l'avez la points d'accès domicile pour
moi sera le plus sécurisé le travail
sera quand même aussi relativement
sécurisé et puis ensuite les points
d'accès publics alors là je vous
conseille quand même de prendre un vpn
mais c'est pas la question aujourd'hui
on pourra en parler une prochaine fois
et ensuite vous contrôlez quel logiciel
quelle application a accès à internet
selon les différents profils
domicile/travail point d'accès public
vous pouvez dire tiens chez moi tout
peut avoir accès internet lorsque tu
seras pas lasser public et bien déjà
plus limité peut-être parce que j'ai
moins de bande passante ou que je veux
vraiment contrôlé ce qu'ils devaient
s'attendre là vous pouvez venir ensuite
le choisit donc ça c'est plutôt cool et
vous pouvez venir tout règle et vous
permet donc d'identifier et de bloquer
tous les logiciels douteux est ce que
j'aime beaucoup aussi avec l'application
que je trouve que c'est très intuitif
vous comprenez réellement ce qui se
passe à tout moment quel que soit votre
profil
donc ça c'est vraiment cool la troisième
partie non des moindres c'est content de
barrières pour moi j'ai un petit garçon
de 5 ans et demi et je veux pas
forcément qu'ils aient accès à tous sur
internet lorsque je peux faire c'est de
créer des profils en fonction des
projets que j'avais alors moi j'ai deux
profils sur mon ordi
aurélien et or l2 pour venir goûter si
toutefois j'ai un problème sur mon
premier profil je n'ai pas créé le
profil pour mon fils pour en créer un et
l on voit ce qu'il peut faire c'est
venir dire bah tiens for health it up
aftu accès tu n'as pas accès tu peux
venir ensuite tout configurer ici tout
est bloqué
je peut autoriser l'accès à tous les
sites web je peux bloquer certains sites
web
je peut planifier des accents match a
toujours accès à internet entre telle et
telle période sera accessoires entre je
sais pas moi 5 heures et 6 heures pour
vous puissiez vraiment venir
si vous êtes parent peut régler l'accès
internet à vos enfants qui n'est pas que
ça tout et n'importe quoi vous pouvez
autorisé ou pas des discussions vous
pouvez venir enregistrer les frappes de
clavier enregistré la fenêtre principale
pour savoir exactement ce qui se passe
ça ordinateur plan de votre enfant
naviguent sur internet pour venir
bloquer des applications et vous et pas
mal de possibilités pour surveiller les
emails vous pouvez bloquer des
connexions vers des serveurs de jeu si
vous voulez pas qu'il est chaud il
voulait pas qu'ils téléchargent vous
pouvez bloquer le peer to peer n ya pas
mal de petites solutions et ça en tant
que parent je trouve ça quand même
vraiment rassurant ensuite en tout cas
c'est intéressant c'est la washing
machine machine c'est une machine à la
et vous et pouvoir nettoyer votre
ordinateur comme vous souhaitez vous
appuyez vous l'avez c'est cool vous
pouvez recyclé supprimer les doublons
pouvait venir organiser l'intérêt 6
exhaustivement voulait pouvoir supprimer
les doublons de fichiers supprimés
tous les programmes que vous n'utilisez
pas récupérer de l'espace disque
supprimer des fichiers de cash obsolète
pourrait venir ensuite supprimer des
fichiers de langues étrangères que vous
ne parlez pas l'idée c'est de dire
complètement optimiser votre machine
gagner en fluidité gagne en rapidité
gagner en espace disque et dernier point
c'est celui-là c'est le personal backup
là vous voulez sauvegarder votre
ordinateur vous combinez cela avec le
time machine d'apple ça marche
parfaitement bien et en plus qui est
vachement intéressant si vous pouvez
créer des sauvegardes démarre à blé
sauvegarde bootable si votre ordinateur
plante ne vous avez une sauvegarde peut
venir démarrer directement depuis votre
sauvegarde pour venir récupérer votre
votre travail récupérer votre ordi vous
avez toute une partie de synchro pour la
sauvegarde et ce que j'aime bien est ce
que je trouve intéressant c'est que
c'est intuitif c'est facile on comprend
bien on voir réellement ce qui se passe
donc ça c'est vraiment cool
bon voilà ça peut pas tout pour
aujourd'hui je vous invite à venir ce
que vous en pensez en bons commentaires
qu est ce que vous pensez de ces
questions de sécurité liées à votre mac
est ce que vous pensez que votre mac et
sécurisé où ils n'ont quoi comment
comment vous trouvez ce logiciel est ce
que vous le trouvez faire arroser
est ce que vous le trouver intéressant
voilà vous marquez tous en bas je vous
ferai d'autres contenus ici en vacances
depuis l'île maurice
regardez-moi ça on est quand même
relativement palais est ce que vous êtes
parti en vacances est ce que vous partez
est ce que vous êtes en vacances tout de
suite marquer moi tout ça prétend pas
température de votre côté savoir comment
se passent vos vacances vous marquez
tout ça je vous embrasse au rendez vous
très rapidement il n'y a pas une vidéo
par jour pendant les vacances je me
prends un petit temps de off avant de
repartir chargés à bloc plein de
nouveautés un nouveau studio a parfois
je veux parler de ça d'ici quelques
jours
pour l'instant on se recharge et puis on
sécurise sa bécane voilà un bisou ciao
[Musique]